any delegation that goes to Keith this
day from another part of the world
always has to have a peace plan with it
and the African leaders who are there
today and going to Moscow tomorrow of
course they've got a peace plan
um these African leaders are not
particularly representative of the 55
members of the African Union and they
have rather taken the Russian view of
the war they accept President Putin's
narrative on what this war is all about
so it's good for Ukraine that these
people have gone to Kiev first it gives
zelinski a chance to show his side of
the picture and see if he can shift
their perceptions a little bit when they
go tomorrow to see President Putin in
Moscow of course they'll be talking
about this peace plan they've got but
really the agenda they will have is to
try to persuade President Putin not to
duck out of the grain deal the really
important grain deal which helps get uh
grain onto the world markets last year
it was almost a catastrophe in terms of
world food prices and food insecurity
and it'll be worse this year if the
grain deal which is at present hanging
by a thread is not renewed now I suspect
that though there's not much in this in
terms of sessions from Ukraine or the
West in continuing the grain deal I
think President Putin May well continue
the grain deal because he's playing a
bigger game with African politics and
and politicians the Russians are heavily
involved in the Civil War in Libya
they're heavily involved in the Civil
War in Sudan they have been very heavily
involved in Diamond Rich Central African
Republic they're already about 1500
Wagner fighters in the Central African
Republic as well as in Mali and in Libya
and in Sudan but the 1500 Fighters there
have been there for quite some time and
the Central African Republic are
offering the uh the Russians a military
base there for between five and ten
thousand troops so President Putin is
playing a very big game in Africa trying
to bring Africa on board not just for
resources and Military cooperation and
trade but also to get there backing for
his version of what the war is all about
he sees the war as part of a shift in
global politics and he wants Africa on
board we'll see how successful he is at
doing that at the United Nations General
Assembly I would imagine in September
when the big meeting the big
international meeting takes place and
we'll just see how much backing the
Russians still have in other parts of
the world it's been quite high so far
meanwhile in the rest of the war
um it goes on this is the 478th day of
the offensive of the of the war itself
the Russian offensive and the 12th day
of the Ukrainian offensive and it's
going on in three areas in back much in
valika novasilka and at oric Cave
towards topmac not very much has
happened in that areas in those areas so
far over the last couple of days because
neither side has yet committed their
main forces they're both probing both
feeling each other's out each other out
the Russians have not done it all badly
they've been very competent so far but
the ukrainians haven't yet committed
most of their big forces that's
something we will see in the next week
or two I would imagine but not quite yet